HASAN, THANKS FOR JOINING US.
WE'RE SO HAPPY YOU'RE HERE.
HERE IS THE THING, IF
NOTHING ELSE, YOU GOT TO
FEEL BAD FOR THE
CONGRESSMAN'S FATHER.
>> NO.
I DON'T FEEL BAD FOR HIS
FATHER.
AND I DON'T FEEL BAD FOR THE
TAXPAYERS.
DO YOU KNOW WHO I FEEL BAD FOR?
>> Jon: NO.
>> THE INTERNS.
>> Jon: WHAT?
>> YEAH, THEY WERE LIVING
THE GOOD LIFE, JON.
AND NOW THERE'S NO MORE
ROMAN CANDLES OUT OF CUPCAKE
BOOB'S.
WHAT DO THEY HAVE LEFT?
>> Jon: SO HE DOESN'T TAKE
INTERNS TO CONCERTS ANYMORE,
THEY STILL GET COLLEGE CREDIT
AND A RESUME BOOST, THE TYPICAL
NERDY ASPIRATIONS THAT GOT THEM
IN CONGRESSIONAL --
>> BORING.
>> Jon: OH FOR GOD'S SAKE.
>> WHO WANTS THAT AFTER YOU
FELT THE THRILL OF THE
SCHOCKER!
>> Jon: I DON'T-- PRETTY
SURE THAT'S NOT THE SCHOCKER.
OR-- WELL, OKAY.
OKAY.
POINT IS,-- I UNDERSTAND.
I -- OKAY.
CAN'T THOSE INTERNS JUST
TRANSFER TO ANOTHER
CONGRESSIONAL OFFICE?
WOULDN'T THAT --
>> YEAH, THAT'S GOING TO
LOOK GREAT ON INSTAGRAM, JON.
HERE'S ME WITH REPRESENTATIVE
SENSENBRENNER WHILE HE READS
THE BILL I JUST PHOTOCOPIED
FOR HIM.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY LIKES
THAT'S GOING TO GET?
>> Jon: NO.
>> ZERO.
NO KID DESERVES ZERO LIKES.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW, HASAN, I
REALLY THINK THEY'LL BE
FINE.
>> THEY WILL, THEY WILL BE
BECAUSE YOU CAN MAKE A REAL
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIFE OF A
FORMER AARON SCHOCK INTERN.
I STARTED A  TRIPSTARTER
CAMPAIGN TO SEND THE INTERNS
TO ALL THE EXCURSIONS THEY
WOULD HAVE GOTTEN TO GO ON
IF SCHOCK HADN'T RESIGNED.
I'M TALKING ABOUT COACHELLA, I'M
TALKING ABOUT SPRING BREAK IN
CANCUN AND I'M TALKING ABOUT
THAT HARRY POTTER THEME PARK AT
UNIVERSAL STUDIOS. YEAH.
>> Jon: DUDE, DUDE, LET ME
TELL YOU SOMETHING, THAT'S
LIKE YOU'RE AT [BLEEP] HOGWARTS.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
>> IT IS, IT IS. IT IS!
>> Jon: EVEN WHEN IT'S HOT
OUT AND THEY'RE STILL
WEARING THE SWEATERS.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> I MEAN, BUT NOW THESE
POOR INTERNS WILL BE FORCED
TO LIVE AS MUGGLES.
>> Jon: MUGGLES?
>> YEAH. UNLESS YOU CHIP IN.
JON, FOR A ONE TIME DONATION
OF JUST $156,000-- .
>> Jon: WOW.
>> YOU CAN HELP A DYING
KID'S WISH COME TRUE.
>> Jon: THEY'RE NOT DYING.
THEY'RE JUST --
>> AREN'T WE ALL, JON?
I MEAN TECHNICALLY AREN'T WE
ALL?
>> Jon: I GUESS SO.
>> I MEAN YOU FASTER THAN
MOST, BUT --
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT, THANK
YOU.